another key moment in the opening up of
the uk it's worth just looking at the
covert 19 data
of cases and we can see here cases
around the world since the start of the
year
and how they've gone down in many
countries but up in some so you can see
in sweden they're starting to climb in
france they're starting to climb
as well and what i'm going to do is just
add on the uk line so you can see how
the uk compares
with other countries and look it's quite
a striking story isn't it
uk cases falling falling falling falling
falling in such that now actually i'll
zoom in here
you can just about see that uk line
is below the japanese line that's pretty
significant because you'll probably know
how that
the japanese line has been very low for
a long time in fact if i go back and
give you some historical perspective
you can see this is more or less the
first time that we've been below the
japanese line
uh since the onset of the pandemic but
here's the thing not so fast because
when you actually look at those numbers
some of what's happening recently to the
uk's lines we're just going back to
that latest chart some of that recent
change is because of an adjustment to
historic
case numbers and if we kind of get rid
of that basically some of the numbers
were revised
if we get rid of that and look at the
underlying change in the numbers well
the uk is still a bit
above japan but still it's a really
promising story going down and down and
down compared with many other countries
which are going up clearly lockdown's
got something to do that also
vaccinations
but here's the thing still a lot of
people worried about hot spots covered
hotspots around the country so although
you've got that
good nationwide figure some people
focusing on different areas of the uk
this is from public health england they
were looking at
bonsley in particular you can see that's
the red bit there well let's just do a
bit of a tour
of different parts of the uk to see how
indeed they compare so
this is our own map here there you can
see the uk the darker these areas are
the more covert 19
there is as a percent of the population
let's zoom into those areas which are
most
effective so-called manager you've got
212 cases
per 100 000 there let's go down
through to corby 126 cases per 100 000
in colby you can see there are different
areas that do have higher levels
compared with the national
average and then you've got bonsai 105
cases per 100 000.
but here's the thing let's just look at
what's actually happening in those areas
so for instance
these are the case numbers that we have
in barnsley so that's
bonsley there um people are looking at
that as a hot spot but actually what you
can see interestingly is there
a lot of cases last autumn but they've
come down and still they're
relatively high but they are kind of a
lot lower than they were
in the autumn whereas look at colby an
enormous increase they missed out on
that spike in the autumn
but around that kind of january period
an enormous spike
in cases in corby and then clap manager
where cases are there are the most cases
at the moment in the
middle of the middle of scotland just
look actually they never really had a
peak in the way that much of the rest of
the country did but right now a little
bit higher
than they usually are it just goes to
show there's nuances here
there is no nationwide picture broadly
speaking all cases are down
but very different stories around
different parts of the uk